hey there and welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend
the podcast that aims to please
uh i'm just trying out
various slogans that one that came into
my head
uh that's no good we don't really aim to
please sorry about that no uh the uh uh
water resistant no uh and safe around
children no no no what the podcast is i
don't know let me try again yeah hey
there and welcome to conor lebron
i liked that i'm so sorry i thought you
were doing more slogans oh no i was
really going to start again i thought
you guys want to be too no we were just
playing no i liked what you were try
again all right well all right let's
shut up let's go don't tell a woman to
shut up girly here we go sorry
and stop doing a cone impression
right here we go hey there and welcome
to conan o'brien needs a friend the
podcast that gets it right every time
whoa i've tried bold statement oh i'm
sorry i'm sorry but i do sometimes think
we need a slogan or something and uh you
know the new york times has all the news
that's fit to print and i think we need
something like that because i think a
recent study shows that most americans
turned to conor bryan needs a friend for
their news
so i think yeah
i didn't even know the new york times
had a slogan when was last time you saw
a newspaper your generation doesn't see
newspapers right well no they it says
all the news that's flipping prince yeah
okay most things used to have a slogan
you know like the titanic you can't sink
me
uh
the hindenburg i'll never blow up um
things had slogans uh and and and i just
thought hey welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend uh this you know the
podcast that aims to please
and your aim will help you you know
you've actually used that slogan before
because we did a segment where you
talked about how it aims to please and
pleases to aim did i say that yeah you
really want to please but i don't think
it it's working come come for matt and
sona stay for conan or come for conan
stay for matt and sona hey how about
conan o'brien needs a friend
we're the show
we got the goods oh boy
uh
this has to potentially fit on a mug
hold on wow that was terrible that did
not sound good you had time to you had
some time you know what i love to do is
promise something big my favorite thing
to do when i was uh on a basketball
court as a kid
was to say check this out and take a
crazy shot and miss completely i thought
that was uh the funniest thing in the
world yeah to promise something with
great confidence remember i used to do
that all the time in the office all the
years we were making late night tv if
anybody had a football i'd call for it
and like what i thought was a really
cool confident way yeah like hey
you know go long go along down here i'm
open and then they would throw it to me
and i would completely flail my arms
and miss it as badly as i could and act
like how did you god damn it watch it
and
that just always made me laugh uh no one
else probably but me but i like that i
like coming in with a lot of confidence
conan o'brien needs a friend the podcast
where you cast the pod we pod
okay let's try this again i'm gonna
count to three and i want you to come in
with so much gusto and then don't think
of a slogan whatever comes out comes out
one two three go hey there and welcome
to conan o'brien needs a friend if
you've got corn we've got cheese and
it's cheddar all the way that's it put
it on the mugs
[Laughter]
you've got corn we've got cheese and
it's cheddar all the way that's
brilliant because it tells you about the
podcast
it's pithy
and brief and it's the way kids talk
today that's right i swear to god i just
one of the things that i think has made
me such a successful recording artist is
that i listen
uh yeah when i go places i listen to
what's happening around me and just
absorb it um even at my advanced stage
and i'm constantly hearing kids say like
hey you've got the call and we've got
the cheese and it's cheddar all the way
that's something
that's happening out there and i'm just
reflecting like any great artist i'm
reflecting back what i'm hearing where
were you when you heard that at a
renaissance fair
and uh
uh a man in the corner who was dressed
as a knight had just had a very he was
having a stroke he was fine they got him
they got him some anticoagulants but he
just out of nowhere said you know you
we've got the call and it's cheddar all
the way you know he he couldn't even say
it right at that point but he's fine now
i don't want to say i'm he's he's better
than fine and uh he's uh he's now an
olympic athlete so everything's fine
oh my god what does it say that that
matt was like don't think just say it
and you said just complete nonsense i
mean should we be concerned about were
you that man having the stroke in the
suit of armor yeah you should be uh
concerned about me the way they were
concerned about picasso oh when he
started uh okay his cubist movement
let's wrap this up